(upbeat music)
We are bursting with hometown spirit this season,
celebrating hometowns all across the country
all season long.
Niccole Mucci is about to show us around her hometown
of Orlando, Florida.
She's a mom and the creator of a website
dedicated to informing families on how to have fun
while learning about being bilingual.
Watch this.
Welcome to Orlando!
My name's Niccole Mucci and I am the Owner
and Content Creator of the Multicultural Maven,
which is a lifestyle content blog.
I love Orlando because it's diversified.
There's so much to do for families.
I'm gonna take you on a little tour.
Let's go.
Welcome to the town of Celebration!
This place is amazing.
It's located right next to the Disney area,
which is perfect.
You can dine, you can shop, and it has some amazing places
that you and your family can come to.
This is the place you wanna visit
if you wanna get away from the hustle and bustle of Disney
and have some great restaurants to visit and places to stay.
I am here at Lake Eola Park in the downtown part of Orlando.
We love coming here to just hang out at the park,
check out the swan little cars that they have,
you can bicycle on the lake,
and just explore the nearby stuff like the public library,
or just do some exercises with homeschool.
Hi guys, and welcome to Wekiwa Springs State Park.
It's a great place to come, get away from the beach,
and there's a lot of things that you could do
with your family, like canoeing and paddleboarding.
I've been coming here since I was in high school,
and we love that the springs are 75 degrees year round.
It's the perfect place to be.
Drew, thanks so much for coming
on this tour of Orlando with me.
As you can see, Orlando has so much for families to do
and people of all ages, so I hope you can come too.
See you soon.
Thanks, Niccole.
We love Orlando.
And of course, I've been numerous times with my daughters
to go to none other than Disney World, Universal,
whatever theme park will have us.
Orlando is so beautiful, and so are you.
(upbeat music)